First dates lecture,
I was talking about a Yates
is early development and,
and stylistic transformation.
Uh,
over the course of roughly a 20,
25 year period. Yates has a long
career, you know, really beginning, uh,
uh, in the, uh, you
know, late 19th century.
And when, when we, the,
the poems that matter
the most to us today, um,
are those that he starts
publishing around 1915, uh,
uh, in 1914, uh, and, and
later, uh, but, uh, you know,
that he's in really the middle
of his, his, um, uh, uh,
literary career at that point. Um, I,
I suggested in looking at
that early development, um,
that, uh, uh, well Yates is,
is seen as a kind of representative
figure who somehow, uh,
moves out of, um, uh, symbolism,
uh, out of, uh, kind of, uh, uh,
ordinate aestheticism towards
a kind of heroic realism.
Um, but I, I insisted instead
that in fact the, the,
the way though to understand
that development is really
a transition from one
set of symbols to another. Um, uh,
as exemplified by the,
the movement between,
uh, uh, Angus and the fishermen in,
in Yates is a early work,
um,
uh, the, uh, little poem, a coat,
a that poem about that
stylistic transformation, um,
about the, the enterprise of
walking naked. Uh, well, uh,
it's,
it's a poem that that reminds us that
Yates is development was as he understood
it, conditioned by his
relationship to his audience.
A Yates I said wanted to speak
for and to the Irish people,
uh, as well as, uh, to explain, uh, uh,
Ireland and Irishness to an
English speaking world, uh,
abroad. At the same time, uh,
even as he has a kind of
intense, uh, identification
with the Irish people, uh,
he also in that little poem and,
and other pumps fears being
betrayed by the crowd, uh,
fears being sold cheap,
uh, complains of, of,
uh, uh, complains of his reception.
Last time I,
uh,
alluded to Yates is involvement
in the Abbey Theater,
uh, beginning in 1904. This is
an important phase of his career.
When with the help of
Lady Augusta Gregory, uh,
and John Singh, uh, Yates, uh,
tries to establish an
Irish national drama,
uh, sings, play the playboy of the
Western world, which you may know,
uh, it was set in the Aran Islands, uh,
in western Ireland.
Uh,
this was a kind of turning point in
the movement under misunderstood,
uh, as a, as a satire on
the Irish peasant tree.
A Yates is a production of the play,
uh,
led to riots in 1909.
And this is one of the,
uh, uh, events. Uh,
I think that Yates is a thinking about
in the fishermen when he speaks of great
art, beaten down, uh,
the audience that Yates,
uh,
disdains and turns away from in the teens,
is, uh, importantly, uh, uh,
middle class urban audience.
Um, and, and that, that
attitude of is, uh, it's,
it's a motif. Uh, we find, uh,
in other poets that we'll read and,
uh, uh, I'd like you to, to, um, um,
note it, uh, an attitude that we'll
see in pound, uh, in Elliot in,
in different ways.
The displacement of,
uh,
aristocratic and peasant
cultures by, uh, an urban, uh,
Bruges Z, uh, by that bat, the Dublin
theater going audience, the, the,
uh, the people at the
center of a new, uh, uh,
uh, Mongrel, uh, modern culture. Uh,
well these are the people that
Joyce depicts. So memorably, uh,
in the daily life of Leopold bloom,
uh,
Yates is a very different writer and
has a different relation to the world of
Joyce's. Ulysses, for
example, a Yates has a,
has a kind of hostility towards
this, uh, ascendant, uh,
middleclass world in a hostility that
you can view as a kind of anti modernism.
Uh, and we're anti
modernness, uh, that is again,
an important component in Yates,
uh,
or, or maybe the right way to
say it would be that Yates,
his sense of his own modernity of what
it means for him to be modern, uh,
emerges in, in, um, a defiance of, uh,
certain, uh, uh, new, uh,
uh, social formations.
Uh,
and also through a fantasy,
I say,
uh,
identification with the
aristocracy and with the peasantry,
uh,
with these cultures rooted in a
rural Irish Society of the past
like pound, uh, like Elliot, uh,
from a political and a
social point of view,
you could say that Yates is
a reactionary modernist, uh,
turning away from the ascendant social
forms of the present towards a idealized
past.
Or rather you could say,
Yates seems to want to do this,
seems to want to turn
away from the present. Uh,
expresses the desire to, in fact, however,
uh,
Yates,
his eyes remain really fixed in the
kind of horror and fascination on the,
a cataclysmic events of his time on the
political life of his time in which he
is himself. Very much involved. Uh,
Yates is in fact a,
a far less nostalgic thinker
then either Elliot or pound,
at least as I understand the,
uh, the, the stance that I'm,
I'm trying to describe,
which is a kind of ambivalent
and complicated one, uh,
emerges a powerfully, uh, in,
in the Palm Easter 1916, uh, uh,
on page one oh five.
And in this book,
and I'd like to spend some
time with that with you.
Easter 1916, uh, the subject
of this poem is the Easter Uprising.
Okay.
The Irish Republican challenge to English
domination that briefly established an
Irish state that led
by Patrick, uh, Pierce,
uh, who, uh, along with, uh, in fact,
all but one of the leaders of
the insurrection was executed.
Uh, these events have, uh, you know,
still have a kind of central
and powerful place in,
in modern IRS consciousness.
If you,
you'd go to Dublin and
you enter the post office,
the one of the important
scenes of the, uh, rebellion,
uh,
you,
you find great a wall
paintings of scenes from,
uh, from the, the rising,
uh, almost, you know,
stations of the cross. Um, uh,
the, uh, uh,
well Dublin is an interesting place
to be with this poem and mine,
uh, partly because you, you realize, uh,
when you were there that that it's
the city center is a small one.
Uh, and that, um, well Yates has houses,
was not far from uh, the
post office. Uh, and,
uh, the um, uh,
world that he's writing about
a is something, uh, very, uh,
intimate and familiar, uh,
of which he is a part a.
And that is in fact one of the important
points of departure for this poem.
He says,
I have met them at close of day coming
with vivid faces from counter or desk
among gray, 18th century houses, Dublin,
them being the revolutionaries
I have passed with a nod of the head
or polite meaningless words or I've
lingered a while and said polite,
meaningless words and thought before I
had done of a mocking tail or a jibe to
please a companion around
the fire at the club.
Being certain that they in I but lived
where motley is worn all changed,
changed utterly.
A terrible beauty is born
motley signifying their
Irishness as if Yates and,
and these men and women.
He speaks of shared only their Irishness.
In the second stroph fee of this poem,
he proceeds to talk about
to isolate individuals,
uh, particular, uh, figures,
uh, of the revolt, which, uh,
uh, your, uh,
editor identifies at the bottom of the
page that woman's days were spent in
ignorant goodwill.
Her nights in argument
until her voice grew shrill.
What voice more sweet than hers. When
young and beautiful she rode to Harriers.
This man had kept a school in Rhode,
our winged horse,
this other, his helper and
friend was coming into his force.
He might've won fame in the end.
So sensitive is nature seemed
so daring and sweet is thought.
This other man I had dreamed
a drunk and vainglorious loud.
He had done most bitter wrong to
some who were near my heart mud gun,
yet I number him in the song.
He too has resigned his part.
He in the casual comedy,
he too has been changed in his turn,
transformed utterly a
terrible beauty is born
gates. This is describing his interaction
with uh, uh, and his distance from,
uh, purse, uh, and the
others in that first stanza.
And then in the second he's
saying something like, uh,
I used to see these people all the time.
Uh,
I was proud,
however,
I kept myself apart from them.
I felt we had nothing in common
but motley, uh, our Irishness.
But all that is changed by events.
They have become political
martyrs to the future Irish state.
And I am obliged to remember
and honor them in my poetry.
Even those I disdained my poetry,
uh, which, well,
the dedication to which had defined
Yates's difference from them up till now.
The poems,
extraordinary refrain,
a terrible beauty is born.
Uh,
it returns in the poem like,
uh,
uh, like a chorus, uh,
like the voice of some kind of
abstract and impersonal chorus.
Uh, and it, it, um,
suggests a,
almost a strangely impersonal event.
Something that happens,
uh,
without agents making it happen.
A terrible beauty is born
a passive construction.
Uh,
take the first part of the
refrain first all changed,
changed, utterly, all changed,
changed utterly.
I think they've really three strong
metrical accents in a row there.
Uh,
by all
that three letter word,
uh,
highly [inaudible] word and word Yates
loves to use. You'll see, you'll see him,
uh,
use it often.
Yates means all of all of those people,
all the people I've been describing,
he also means my relation to them,
the way I kept myself apart from them.
Uh,
he also means all,
uh,
everything plain and simple awe in
the sense of everyone and everything,
all conveying a kind of
apocalyptic apical event.
That wonderful pile up of
stress in that line all changed,
changed utterly.
A terrible beauty is born.
Another two, two strong, three beat
lines in a row, they become a kind of,
well, what a bell ringing in the poem, uh,
peeling, uh, and, and, uh, uh, uh,
announcing the coming of the
birth of a new and terrible age.
How can something be
changed utterly? Uh, it's,
it's how can, how can something
be changed utterly? Uh,
it doesn't that mean destroyed,
uh,
to be entirely changed.
Uh,
Yates is,
is
talking about an event that has
brought forth a destruction,
a destruction of the world
before the Easter uprising.
And Easter is an important resonance here.
Obviously a Easter,
another moment, uh, of
death and transfiguration,
Trans Trans Formation, uh, here.
Uh,
this destruction brings forth a new order,
a new form of life that
Yates cause terrible beauty.
Uh, this may be the most memorable, uh,
sentence in modern poetry.
A terrible beauty is born.
I said that, that Yates
looks on, uh, uh, the modern,
uh, with a sense of both the
whore and, and a fascination of,
of compulsion. Uh, almost, uh, well, uh,
it's a terrible beauty. He sees
that, that that draws him. Uh,
in this way he sees the specifically
the passion of the Revolutionaries Act.
Any fines that beautiful Yates
aestheticizes their political action.
He finds beauty in it.
It seems even,
or especially because it is terror filled
when the change, uh,
that it enacts is utter,
uh, which is to say, ah,
a change.
That means blood
define bloody events. Beautiful.
What do you think about that?
How do you, how do, how do you describe
the, the, uh, the politics, uh,
if he like, uh, of, of such a position?
Uh,
well,
how does the gates stand in relation
to the events he's describing?
Easter 1916, equivocates, uh,
like that phrase, terrible beauty. Uh,
the palm is full of contradictions
of contradictory feelings.
It takes the side of the nationalists.
It also makes the ante nationalists the
English or pro English or unionist case.
It sees the dead as heroic martyrs.
Uh,
it also sees them as,
uh, uh, ideologues, uh,
as a,
uh,
as a Stoney hearted,
um, uh, uh, political activists,
uh,
it sees the dead as lovers to,
it sees them as dreamers.
A Yates looks at them with pity,
with admiration,
with scorn. Uh, he speaks of them
as a mother would
have her children.
Uh,
all of these attitudes and others to are,
are, uh, are held in suspension
in the palm. And, uh,
you can hear them together. Uh,
Yates moving from one to another,
uh, with Oh, uh, uh,
uh,
incredible speed and agility in
that final straw fee of the poem.
On the,
the next
Paige,
listen to, uh, to how quickly
Yates modulators from one,
one feeling, uh, one image, uh,
to another in these really very short,
a quick three beat lines.
Too long a sacrifice can
make a stone of the heart.
Oh,
when may it suffice?
That is heaven's part our part to murmur.
Name upon name as a mother named her
child when sleep at last has come limbs
that had run wild. What
is it? But nightfall,
no, no, no, not night,
but death was it needless death after
all for England may keep faith for all
that has done and said,
we know their dream enough to know they
dreamed in our dead in what if excess of
love bewildered them till they died.
I write it out in a verse,
Mcdonough and Mcbride and Connolly and
Pearse now and in time to be whatever
green is worn are changed,
changed utterly.
A terrible beauty is born.
This is really moving poetry.
Uh, you know, remarkably so.
Uh, and that may be the most
important fact about it.
Uh,
when Yeats aestheticizes the political,
uh, he makes it moving, uh,
moving in the literal sense of,
uh,
I think emotionally engaging in Cathartic,
he can specifically converts the
political into tragic action,
tragic action, which as spectators, uh,
the poet and the reader, ourselves, uh,
are meant to be passionately
and imaginatively engaged.
Uh,
which is also to say implicated
through hates his poem. Uh,
Easter 1916 goes on, happening,
uh, happening, uh, in a sense,
uh, uh, in and, and, and,
and even to us,
the poem makes us see the political as
a space of passion and of contradictions
like art. Uh, and it requires
us to understand history,
not in moral terms, uh,
such as good and evil,
but rather in aesthetic terms,
a pity and terror.
These become crucial terms.
Uh, the terms that, uh,
Aristotle in his poetics
used to define tragedy.
Uh, when the, when the bombs went off in,
in London last year, uh, I
thought about, Yay, it's,
and, and, and, and, uh, what he might
have thought or written about this as I,
as I said last time when I showed
you that letter to pound his, uh,
uh, Yates is, um, London apartment, uh,
is essentially across the street
from where the number 30 bus blew up.
Uh, and interestingly, um,
strangely make of it what you
will, the man who, uh, uh,
detonated that a bomb, uh,
as I understand it, uh,
had studied the aids, uh,
at school and in leads.
Uh,
there's a,
there's a way in which he hates
his poetry of this period,
uh, goes on resonating in, in, uh,
the world we're, we're
living in Yates's Yates.
His sense of his own
implication in, in history, uh,
well it's something that we see in the,
uh,
intensive stylistic transformations
that his writing undergoes
a part of the resonance and
power of that famous refrain,
a terrible beauty is born.
Uh,
is that this beauty is being born not
only in the world, but in Yates is poetry.
Uh, something remarkable is
happening, uh, to, uh, the poet, uh,
and to, uh, his, his language.
At the same time a Yates is saying,
even simply on one level, I will
write differently. Henceforth,
I must, uh, Yates is stylistic.
Changes in this way,
are coordinated with respond to the
historical changes he witnesses and
participates in, uh,
in particular, uh, uh,
coordinated with the violent,
uh, emergence of, uh,
through civil war of,
of the Irish state,
which Yates would serve as a senator,
uh,
in the 1920s.
Yates in this period makes and
remakes his work out of passion,
uh, sort of as he images
to malt in the breast,
uh, uh, a, uh, uh,
to Molt from which new modes of poetry,
new modes of self knowledge,
uh,
emerge for Yates.
Yates is poetry is full
of images of birth, uh,
and he tends to represent
birth as an explosion,
a bursting forth, a bursting
forth of, of energy,
uh, or presence, uh,
in some sense that can't be contained
or constrained in existing forms.
Uh,
I'll say,
I'll say more about this next time
with reference to Yates is late poetry.
Uh,
what I want to stress now is
that Yates sees passion at work.
Uh, in the same way in history. Uh,
powerful superhuman forces emerge from
or invade a human actors and change.
Uh, one consequence of this
view is that for Yates,
a history starts to look
like a palm, uh, or, uh,
it starts to conform to laws of
poetic imagination or of tragedy,
if you like,
uh, of myth. Uh, it, uh,
well,
uh,
in the Easter rising,
purse and the other's for Yates,
uh, invoke, uh, as, as they,
the revolutionaries themselves
deliberately and rhetorically did, uh,
invoke ancient Irish
heroes, uh, uh, purse,
uh,
is seen as in Yates,
as poetry and in popular lore as
Hoolan as a kind of Avatar of,
of, uh, um, uh, you know, the, uh, um,
uh, mythic Irish hero,
uh, at the same time,
uh,
as the superhuman enters these
historical characters in this way,
uh, there's also, uh, well, um, uh,
um, an energy that you would have
to call subhuman, uh, be steel.
Uh, that does, uh, as
well. Uh, in his late poem,
the statutes, which you
don't have, Yeats says,
um, uh, um,
what, uh, when, when, um, uh, Paris, uh,
summoned Coolin to his side,
what stopped through
the post office as if,
uh, the revolutionaries action, um, uh,
brought forth at once,
uh,
the presence of a legendary
hero and a beast that might,
uh, be stocking, uh, through his,
his embodiment in his presence.
Yates saw history in symbolic
and mystical terms. Uh,
this is a poet who, with his
wife, practiced automatic writing,
who believed that the dead
spoke through the living this,
this a cult.
Yates is,
is a genuinely and wonderfully
strange thinker. Uh,
he elaborated a systematic,
a account of mind in history.
Uh, and as I said last time talking
about the song of Wandering Angus, uh,
and, and Yates is interest in
Alchemy, which was developed. Uh,
it isn't in fact necessary
for you to grasp.
Yates is system which
you'd have to go to his,
a book called a vision,
uh, to begin to do.
It doesn't necessary,
uh,
for you to grasp is a cultism in order to,
read his poetry. Uh, well, uh,
Yeats said that the,
the voices that he communicated with a
on the other side gave him a metaphors
for poetry. This is what they,
this is what they deliver him. Uh,
they also gave him, as he put it,
stylistic arrangements of experience.
Uh, this, the,
the cult gives
Yates aesthetic forms for understanding,
um,
individual psychology and
historical event. This is,
I think, uh, how we need
to understand, uh, the, uh,
the various, a cult
symbols, uh, in, in, uh,
another great, uh, poem, uh,
from this phase in his career.
A little bit further on the
second coming, uh, on page one 11.
Hmm.
Uh,
turning and turning in the widening gyre.
The Falcon cannot hear the falconer.
Things fall apart.
The center cannot hold.
Mere anarchy is loosed upon the world.
The blood dimmed tide
is loosed in everywhere.
The ceremony of innocence is drowned.
The best lack all conviction,
while the worst are full
of passionate intensity.
Surely some revelation is at hand.
Surely the second coming, is
it hand? The second coming?
Hardly are those words out.
When a vast image out of
Spiritus Mundi troubles my site,
somewhere in sands of the desert,
a shape with lion body
and the head of a man,
a gaze blank.
And Pinellas as the sun is moving,
it's slow thighs while all about it.
Real shadows of the
indignant desert birds,
the darkness drops again.
But now I know the 20
centuries of stony sleep,
we're vexed to nightmare by a
rocking cradle and what rough beast,
its hour come round at last slouches
towards Bethlehem to be born.
Another poem of birth.
Uh,
notice how very casual Yates is in that
second stair OFI how self consciously
fantastic and speculative he is.
He doesn't insist that the apocalypse
is at hand only that some revelation is,
uh, in fact, uh, this poem's power, uh,
lies I think in it's, uh,
not only its inability,
but it's unwillingness to specify
the content of that revelation.
Yates suggests that we think of this
historical moment as the second coming,
but this is not the return of Jesus that
Christianity prophesizes Yates sees the
second coming as an image, as
a myth and idea, a metaphor,
a certain stylistic
arrangement of experience.
It comes out of what he
calls spiritus. Mundi. Okay.
Semi technical term a Yates is name
for something like the collective
unconscious of all peoples. A kind
of repertoire of, of archetypes,
uh, from which the symbols that we
use to understand the world derive,
uh, it is, uh, um,
this, uh, this is, well,
this is really I think a,
um,
a radical if not heretical idea for the
national poet of a Christian people.
Uh,
Yates is saying that Christianity is
only one symbolic order among others.
It has a history.
Uh,
it is now passing away as
it once came into being.
And he's also saying that the birth of
Christ in Bethlehem was a nightmare for
the world.
It altered the world
that it changed utterly.
It change that Yates sees as the end
now of the Christian ear and not its
fulfillment.
There's isn't there to the disturbing
suggestion that Christ himself was a rough
beast.
Uh,
Yates developed this idea or develops
another version of it in a somewhat
earlier pump. Uh, that's interesting
in relation to this one. And let's,
let's turn back and look at
it. Uh, on page one of three,
uh, that the Madge I, um,
uh, again, visionary poem,
uh, where Yates is saying, ah,
I see,
I see in my mind's eye,
this is the action of the poem
takes place in Yates is imagination.
Now, as at all times, I can
see in the mind's eye in there,
stiff, painted, close, the Pale,
unsatisfied ones appear and disappear
in the blue depth of the sky with all
their ancient faces like rain,
beaten stones in all their Helms
of silver hovering side by side,
and all their eyes still fixed.
Hoping to find once more being by
calvary's turbulence unsatisfied.
The uncontrollable mystery
on the beast steel floor,
the Madge I hear are again, a, an image,
a kind of visionary symbol,
uh,
an image available in the
mind's eye at all times.
Uh,
they are unsatisfied by
calvaries turbulence,
Calvary's turbulence.
Uh,
remarkable phrase,
uh,
unsatisfied by the scene
of Christian martyrdom,
uh,
because they recognize
that history is cyclical,
uh,
and that the cycle that they saw coming
to being can only be completed by
another such birth,
uh,
not by Christ's death and resurrection.
Notice here how, um, uh, Yates images.
Okay.
What does that, the core
of Christ's birth? Uh,
it is an uncontrollable mystery
on the beast steel floor on the floor,
uh, on the bottom, uh, on the ground,
uh, where the animals dwell. Uh, okay.
The second coming, uh,
it seems is a, is, um,
as Yates imagines that I kind of similarly
unclear controllable mystery and the,
the, uh, the energy, uh, the,
the new presence that it
releases into the world, uh, is,
uh, is that of a beast. The, uh,
the divine enters the human
in these poems of Yates,
uh,
through the beast steel.
It's a powerful and disturbing idea.
Uh, there's a, uh,
another very powerful and disturbing poem,
uh, that literalize as this idea. Uh,
and that is later.
And the Swan on page one 18,
a, a, a poem that is a sonnet though.
It doesn't quite look like it at first.
Uh,
a mythological poem,
uh,
that
seeks to give a
mythological image two or for the kinds of
okay.
Epical and apocalyptic
historical change that,
uh, Yates is living through, uh,
in the 1920s in Ireland.
Uh, it's a, it's a, in
certain ways it's a,
it's a beautiful palm and a grotesque one.
Uh,
at the same time,
uh,
a sudden blow
the great wings beating still
above the staggering girl,
her thighs caressed by the dark
webs her nape caught in his bill.
He holds her helpless
breast upon his breast.
How can those terrified vague fingers
push the feathered glory from her
loosening thighs?
And how can body laid in that white
rush but feel the strange heart beating
where it lies
a shutter in the loins,
in genders there,
the broken wall,
the burning roof and
tower and Agamemnon dead
being so caught up,
so mastered by the blood of the air.
Did she put on his
knowledge with his power
before the indifferent
beak could let her drop
history?
What makes history happen is imaged here
in the form of the rape of the human by
the divine
in the form
of a beast.
The form of a Swan,
the myth that Yates takes up is a of
Zeus is rape of, of the maiden later,
uh, whom he attacks, uh, as a swan. Uh,
the offspring that the rape
in gender, uh, includes Helen,
the terrible beauty for whom
the Trojan war was fought.
Uh, also quite Clytemnestra, uh,
the wife of the Greek Lord Agamemnon,
whom Clayton Nestra murders
on his return from Troy.
Uh, those future events, our,
our, uh, our, our glimpsed in the, in the,
the, uh, [inaudible] of this
poem and the final six lines, uh,
they are in a sense a compressed and
imaged and contained in the rape itself.
Uh, there's a, there's a kind
of radical foreshortening of,
of temporal experience at a what a Yates
images as the orgasmic union of the
divine and human. A
shutter in the lines, uh,
bringing about the sack of Troy,
uh,
the murder of the king. Uh, all
of that future contained in this,
uh, generative ambiguous violence, uh,
in the presence that the poem describe
the present that the poem describes,
uh, in effect in the, that
middle part of the poem, uh,
Yates collapses creation and destruction,
uh,
suggesting that the same beast steel
energy flows through both of these acts,
uh,
here,
a divine force reduces to brute power,
uh, in somewhat the same way
as it does in the match. I,
and the second coming,
uh,
one result of this is Yates is this is
interesting. His, his lack of interest,
uh, in the God, this
isn't a poem about Zeus.
It's not a poem about the Swan.
Uh, he doesn't name the Swan,
uh, just as he doesn't name the rough
beast, uh, in, in the second coming, uh,
what the swan thinks or feels or intense.
It doesn't matter.
Uh,
the swan is really only a force
and Yates is concerned, is rather with
the human experience of that force.
Uh,
which is again,
another manifestation of terrible beauty.
Uh,
Yates explores that experience,
uh,
which is an experience of
suffering here and a violation,
uh, through a series of
rhetorical questions, uh,
which are a crucial
poetic device for Yates.
Yates is a poet who asks
questions, questions, well,
they're different. Even rhetorical
questions are different, aren't they?
From statements of fact.
They're more like, uh,
propositions like speculations,
uh,
that were asked to test through
empathic identification with,
in this case, uh, the
poem subject Lita, uh,
uh, this, this is, this is what the
form of the question invites I think,
uh,
in eastern 1916,
I talked about Yates as partial
complicated identification
with the suffering
martyrs, uh, of that poem. Uh,
well that identification here is
reimagined and we're invited into it too.
Troublingly I think,
uh,
the frightening,
experience that Yates evokes here is the
imposition of the divine on the human,
uh, helpless breast on breast. Uh, it's a,
that's a wonderful phrase.
The repetition of breast links them,
uh,
makes us see them together side by side,
one on top of the other. It even, I think,
identifies the divine and the human makes
them hard to tell apart a binds them.
Uh, even while we are being
confronted with their difference, uh,
lead leader feels the
beating of the swans heart.
And that heart is strange to her.
That simple,
powerful word,
the poems.
A great final question, uh,
concerns that perception.
Did she put on his
knowledge with his power?
Did she know the heart she
felt or could she only feel it?
What difference would it make
between those two things,
between knowing that heart
and merely feeling it? Uh,
it's the difference between,
uh, knowing, uh, history,
understanding its patterns
and motivating forces, its
causes,
intentions,
and merely feeling it merely suffering it,
uh,
serving as its instrument or vessel in
object to be dropped when it's no longer
useful, uh, to know
history, to be able to,
to put on the God's knowledge with
his power would be to have access to
histories meaning,
uh,
and therefore it to be more
than merely subject to it,
subject to it's capricious
and, and, uh, violating, uh,
forces. Uh, Bill Gates doesn't
answer the question. Does he?
Uh, well, uh, why not?
Probably because there isn't an answer.
Uh,
the further implication is I think that,
um,
whether or not we can have
access to historical knowledge,
the only path to such knowledge is through
submission to it's the steel or brute
power, which is a kind of
shattering experience in this poem.
Uh, well on, on Monday, we'll,
we'll look at some of the
figures in Yates is late poems,
uh, who represent a kind of
knowledge to be had through, uh,
an experience of well violation,
uh,
or of shattering power,
characters such as the mad
old men, uh, or, uh, uh,
crazy. Jane, uh, in the
eights is late poems.